[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales toute
l'équipe du grand jt des territoires se
joint à moi pour vous souhaiter de
belles fêtes de fin d'année tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité
à défaut de pouvoir s'offrir savez vous
commentez fabriquer le caviar surnommé
l'or noir est bien réponse à suivre dans
un reportage de tv7 la chaîne bureau sud
ouest qui nous emmènera dans les
coulisses de sa fabrication
la nouvelle tendance venue de
grande-bretagne ne pas boire d'alcool
une tendance qui fait les affaires d'un
bas à chambéry où se sont rendus les
caméras de 8 mont blanc vous le verrez
un bar qui ne propose que des cocktails
non alcoolisées
2 ou l'isère en plein air dans ce
journal nous irons à la rencontre d'un
pianiste itinérant bjorn c'est son nom
qu'ont rencontré nos confrères de thé
vert se déplace avec son piano pour
jouer vous le verrez le nez au vent et
puis la magie de noël continue de
kilomètres de guirlandes des écrans
plasma josé n'y est pas allé de main
morte un ami dans de conti dans la somme
a mis le paquet question déco de sa
maison comme vous allez le voir à la fin
de ce journal dans un reportage de wéo
la chaîne la voix du nord voilà qui dit
fêtes de fin d'année dit mets
d'exception à commencer par le caviar
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
que l'on ne trouve évidemment pas sur
toutes les tables puisque son prix peut
aller de deux mille à 12000 euros le
kilo tout de même alors à défaut de
pouvoir en manger je vous propose et je
vous le dis en titre d'en découvrir les
secrets de fabrication grâce à bénédicte
doha à noter les 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest qui s'est rendu dans une ferme
des caviars à neuvic en dordogne
regarder le pdg lui-même nous fait
entrer dans les coulisses le caviar
neuvic ses quinze mille mètres cubes
d'eau dédié à la pisciculture biologique
à quelques semaines des fêtes de fin
d'année le compte à rebours est lancé au
total c'est une biomasse de 320 tonnes
de poissons dont il faut surveiller le
développement c'est le caviar ici et en
faisant bouger on arrive à lire le
relief est avec l'habitude d'antoine il
arrive à distinguer la taille de l'offre
l'opération consiste à vérifier par
échographie si le poisson ade ce qui est
le cas pour environ une trentaine de
port sans qu'ils en aient eu soit petit
ou quelques emmène bague donc le poisson
soit reprirent au mois d'août pour la
production de l'an prochain fin de la
saison prochaine ou alors des eac gros
qui part directement au raffinage pour
cette saison après un mois d'affinage on
pourrait le transformer les e récoltés
sont envoyés en laboratoire
ils sont d'abord séparés de leurs
membranes avant d'être nettoyé reims et
plusieurs fois à ce stade ce sont encore
deux simples de d'esturgeon c'est une
fois l'étape suivante réalisé que la
magie opère on est vraiment sur une des
vraies tâches principales de la
l'élaboration du caviar ça va être
l'incorporation du sel donc c'est
vraiment à cette étape là qu'on commence
à parler de caviar c'est quand les oeufs
d'esturgeons sont sales et nous allons
perdre on se veut peu sale ans pour
garder toute la subtilité du caviar et
après ce qui va venir nous différencier
ça va être la qualité des grains et
leurs couleurs et ensuite ça va être les
différentes étapes de maturation qui
vont se passer en chambre froide le
caviar de vix est une production de 5
tonnes et demie de caviar avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 6 millions d'euros
après des fêtes de fin d'année marqué
par la crise sanitaire en 2020 les
prochains mois s'annoncent prometteurs
pendant l'impression qu'il ya un vrai
désir de produits de luxe à plusieurs
titres en fait la crise sanitaire a agi
elle agit aussi vers une relocalisation
vers des produits proche de chez soi et
ça je pense que ça joue un petit peu et
donc j'espère en tout cas que ça
fera un petit peu ça donnera un petit
peu davantage du calvaire français sur
lequel la chine ont par exemple
troisième plus gros producteur de caviar
dans le monde la france en produit
jusqu'à 42 tonnes par an 90 % sont issus
des fermes néo aquitaine
et puis on reste dans les mets
traditionnels nous quittons la nouvelle
aquitaine pour la martinique où la
commune du prêcheur est connu pour son
célèbre beaux yachts ont comme son nom
le laisse penser ce sont des boyaux de
ton blanchi jean-guy gabriela pêcheurs
de la région nous explique ses origines
au micro de johan charpentier titi et de
josé lechertier de via à tv martinique
sur place
jean-guy n'en est pas à son coup d'essai
le boyau ton il est tombé dedans quand
il était petit un plat qui l'a toujours
fasciné au point d'en percer les
moindres secrets j'étais très très
observateur comme j'étais gamin et je
regardais comment il faisait et curieux
aussi s'était posé des questions parce
qu'en fait les yeux la traduc
lalalalalala la tradition fait le savoir
sacré comment c'était en observant on
venait pas comme à l'école pour dire
mais bon voilà eux et que font deux
étapes et afpa n'est pas comme ça la
maîtrise est au rendez vous
les cheveux je fais deux fils s'il n'ya
pas le bonheur
trop bon le bouille au ton plat
incontournable du prêcheur et comme
toute bonne recette traditionnelle elle
a ses origines faut pas oublier que
quand les pêcheurs du sud venait pêcher
au précieux et partait pour la semaine
il fallait donner à manger à ces gens
parce qu'il ya un traître et a7 à la
voile que tu y avait pas de vent j'étais
obligé de notre question au précieux
parce qu'il venait pêcher tout au nord
et fallait donner à manger à ses gens
alors d'abord ça a été du le bouilleur
elite est salée et un jour trop de monde
elle a essayé cette recette logo youtube
clin d'oeil à l'histoire et yasmine
femme de marin pêcheur est venue de
sainte anne pour déguster un bon plat de
boutons c'est une spécialité du nord
nous ont fait pas ça on connais pas du
tout marié marins pêcheurs pourtant mais
on veut vraiment goûté à l'or on a
retenu six un vrai pêcheur et un autre à
mélodie tu sais au restaurant comme ça
on va pouvoir comparer un petit peu ce
que et chaque année on va goûter à
d'autres pari réussi pour les prix
chutent un leurs recettes emblématiques
attire toujours autant les foules
après les plats les boissons dans ce
gîte et connaissez vous cette nouvelle
tendance appelée le naulleau alcool qui
nous vient tout droit de la grande
bretagne
je vous en parlais en titre il s'agit de
ne pas boire ou alors très
raisonnablement comme vous allez le voir
un bar à chambéry est allé visiter lucas
truc de huit tombes l'en est donc
parfaitement dans la mouvance puisqu'il
ne propose que des cocktails non
alcoolisées nous aller voir ça marche
ce bar champ mais rien est bien
particulier il propose des vins
cocktails et spiritueux exclusivement
sans alcool là on a un concombre qui
maintient avec gino dj sont d'accord
l'établissement a vu le jour il ya six
mois grâce à alexandre persuadé que son
idée gagnerait à être plus connus je
deviens de nous accabler est le fléau
numéro 1 de l'amérique à nice et
l'alcool l'alcool c'est le fléau de
chaque problème à peu près 70 80 % donc
du coup j'avais décidé de faire un bar
taux d'alcool parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
sur chambéry du moins pas un vrai bar
avec vins spiritueux etc ce texte a donc
on s'est dit qu'on allait prendre son
challenger c'était peut-être plus
difficile plus risqués mais on soit au
fur et à mesure mais l'on commence à
apprécier ce qu'on fait découvrir que
forcément que les jus connue qu'au quart
avec plus d'une dizaine de créations
originales les boissons de ce bar ont
pour but de faire évoluer les mentalités
sur le sans alcool le vlad iii est l'un
des cocktails phare de ce bar car son
goût ne fait penser à aucun autre c'est
un serveur de ce prix donc le cocktail
un repas italien
qui du coup ramène sur tout le côté
nouveautés agrumes qui qui qui marche
très bien et ce petit ce petit arrière
goût piquant qui peut faire penser à
l'alcool mais qui n'en est pas
finalement maïla antoine et claire sont
partis sur un sirop de mojito il ne
semble pas être déçus de leur choix qui
en plus est une découverte ben déjà
c'est très bon et puis l'alcool ne
manquent pas
nicole ne manquent pas voilà je fais
entre entre amis on discute et puis
c'est exactement la même chose que que
dans un bar normal ce que vous comptez 5
euros pour un cocktail dans ce bar le
juste prix pour réussir à accueillir un
public plus large
voilà et puis si ça vous tente sachez
que le 1er janvier prochain débute le
dry giannoli un défi qui consiste à ne
pas boire du tout pendant un mois bon
courage à tout autre sujet maintenant
dans ce gîte et sachez que 20% des
actifs sont actuellement dans un
processus de reconversion
professionnelle selon le baromètre de la
formation et de l'emploi et parmi eux
vous allez le voir une ancienne
chauffeuse livreuse est une ancienne
éducatrice spécialisée qui sont devenues
stylistes un reportage dans la loire
dans un univers pillon de tl7 la
télévision la loire
depuis quelques semaines un millier
amandine ont radicalement changé leurs
conditions de travail est désormais ces
deux chez elle qu'elle imagine les
lignes de leur future marque de
vêtements notre projet c'est de créer
des vêtements pour un pour les femmes
enceintes et ça c'est des morphologies
qu'on n'a pas forcément étudié à l'école
à car dans quelques mois les espère
lancer une marque made in france et
respectueuse de l'environnement sortir
de la fast fashion et 2 pouvoir proposer
des produits écologiques avec des tissus
qui sont bons pour la santé et bon pour
la nature là on est en train de
découvrir un tissu qui est fabriqué à
base d'algues qui pourrait qui est pas
du tout polluants en termes de
conception et qui pourrait même être bon
pour le corps un virage à 360 degrés par
rapport à leur vie professionnelle d'il
ya un peu plus d'un an amandine était
éducatrice spécialisée et amélie
chauffeur-livreur pendant plus de 15 ans
les choses de la vie ont fait que j'ai
pas pu pas pu attaquer une formation
tout de suite donc j'ai attendu j'ai
attendu que les d'avoir des enfants que
la maison soit finie ce qui a bien collé
en fait c'est que ma boîte a fermé il ya
deux ans j'ai droit à un plan de
licenciement et ceux qui m'ont financer
la formation durant 12 mois elles ont
donc intégré la formation des métiers de
la mode et du vêtement au lycée adrien
testud du chambon feugerolles un vrai
challenge qui nécessitent agilité entre
vie de famille et vie professionnelle et
qu'il a fallu à préparer et mûrir
pendant plusieurs mois à plusieurs
années j'ai fait des allers-retours en
fait dans mon ancien métier je les
quitte y est j'y suis retourné un peu
parce que je je cherchais encore en fait
je ça m'a fait peur de quitter quelque
chose qui était plutôt connu une notion
bien présente à l'esprit des formateurs
du greta ou 215 formations sont
proposées du niveau c ap au bac +3/4
tous les profils et tous les âges ils
garnissent les effectifs la formation
elle concerne les jeunes à partir de 16
ans jusqu'à des personnes qui sont en
reconversion professionnelle jusqu'à d
âge assez avancé
on le verra ce soir sur notre cérémonie
une personne qui va témoigner qui a fait
de reconversion professionnelle et qui a
59 ans donc y'a pas d'âge en réalité
pour un pouvoir se former c'est pour ça
que chez nous on aime parler de
formation tout au long de l'année et
dans la loire ce sont les métiers de
l'industrie du bâtiment et de
l'hôtellerie restauration qui sont les
plus en recherche de nouveaux candidats
voilà puis tout à fait autre chose si
vous vous demandez encore comment
occuper vos enfants pendant ces fêtes
pourquoi ne pas les laisser jouer ou
caissiers alors dans un supermarché
nouveau che dans la loire des enfants
ont pu passer derrière la caisse et au
vu du reportage d'adrien bethery de tl7
cette initiative rencontre un franc
succès regardez
oui devant une borne généralement une
chose si ton fils
voilà après avoir écouté quelques
consignes après avoir pris la main les
articles s'enchaînent sous les yeux
d'une maman plutôt amusant ça va il se
débrouille bien
c'est marrant de voir ça
c'est étonnant je savais pas qu'il
faisait ça ça y est les articles sont
tous vite et il faut payer maintenant a
fait 40
[Musique]
et l'expérience a plu à ce nouveau quai
si oui parce que c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on peut passer les articles
derrière la caisse qu'est ce que bébé
lui mais passer les articles et dire au
client combien ça coûte et
commençait à prendre comme un fr le
magasin netto ne s'interdit rien pour
poursuivre cette initiative en 2022
entre le premier mercredi du mois est
aujourd'hui une dizaine d'enfants s'est
prêté au jeu ça leur permet de canaliser
sur leurs enfants qui s'ennuient pas et
que le puisse ranger leurs courses
tranquillement aussi plutôt qui restent
à s'ennuyer pendant que les parents
scanner rangent leurs courses eh ben il
scanne eux mêmes les articles les
encaisses eux mêmes leurs parents et si
les enfants ont la chance de jouer les
caissiers c'est grâce au gérant du
magasin ou plutôt grâce à son fils de 8
ans qui s'amusait au départ à faire le
marchand
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité si vous êtes en bretagne et
que vous vous promener sur la plage il
se peut que vous tombiez nez à nez avec
un pianiste il s'appelle bjorn gotshal
il est compositeur et ils s'aiment sa
musique aux 80 natacha store de tvr l'a
suivi lors d'une de ses pérégrinations
musicales regarder et surtout écouter
le piano rentrer au millimètre près la
junte a joué au piano dans leur voiture
sentons pas bjorn a pris le coup de main
pour charger l'instrument dans sa
fourgonnette
départ de rennes direction de la côte
d'émeraude
on est à la pointe du grouin voilà fait
un peu froid aujourd'hui je la boucle le
paysage se mérite il faut s'y rendre à
la force des bras
passé le moment intéressant parce que je
sais pas si mon piano a été super
désaccordé ou pas
quelques jours par semaine quand la
météo est clémente le compositeur
s'offrent un entraînement insolite une
manière de tester ses nouveaux morceaux
on a fit bac direct on peut parler avec
les gens on a aussi un espèce de
reconnaissance le plupart du temps où
les gens ils disent ah oui c'est super
et c'est havas a fait du bien aussi et
la musique elle vient plus joyeux si on
écrit aussi que tout seul c'est sûr
pendant quatre à cinq heures d'affilée
la musique accompagne les pas des
marcheurs une rencontre inattendue pour
ces touristes d'isère on trouve que
c'est vraiment avec beaucoup de douceur
avec le paysage c'est c'est un peu
mélancolique mais c'est sympa
presque autodidacte bien de compose des
morceaux à partir d'improvisations jazz
tu as besoin d'écrire les partitions
quelques notes se sont invités sur le
bois du piano j'aime bien avoir un peu
mon tableau ah ouais ça tu sais faire ça
me rassure après je décide et je peux
faire mon programme
dans le moment alors un conseil gaieté
l'horizon un pianiste itinérant on
pourrait s'y trouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans quelques jours nous tirerons les
rois une tradition qui remonte à
l'antiquité le saviez vous et qui dit
tirer les rois dit bien entendu tirer
une fève éventuellement ce précieux
sésame enzo maubert de lmtv s'est
glissée dans l'atelier d'un céramiste à
malicorne sur sarthe en plein de travail
pour nos fans regardez
le geste est délicat le regard concentré
yacine boutaleb céramistes d'art met la
dernière touche aux décors assez petite
fève 600 en tout qui partiront bientôt
dans une célèbre pâtisserie de la flèche
moi j'ai choisi de décorer sur le
biscuit un prêt je vais pouvoir tromper
mas fès dans un bain des mailles et
transparentes qui va nous faire rêver
les
la couleur verte une fois la trempette
réalisé dans le bain des miles direction
le four et après huit heures de cuisson
à plus de 900 degrés le résultat est là
c'est parfait
yacine boutaleb a appris son métier au
maroc il s'est installé à malicorne sur
sarthe en 2015 et a ouvert son atelier
de céramique pour imaginer ses petites
fèves au feuillage vert sa femme artiste
elle aussi l'a beaucoup inspiré et là
vraiment ce don de faire ce dessin très
fin
des fois répétitif des fois vraiment
unique mais mais que j'aime bien et que
j'ai essayé de reproduire sur les fait
tomber amoureux du savoir faire local
yacine réalise de la vaisselle le reste
de l'année des créations toujours
uniques et faites à la main ce qui
m'intéresse lui c'est de créer c'est
vraiment de trouver des objets qui est
qui font la loi ou chez le client sait
c'est vraiment le but c'est ça c'est le
but ultime en tout le céramiste
réalisera plus de 3000 fais pour
différentes boulangeries alors en
janvier ouvrez l'oeil vous manquerez
peut-être de vous casser les dents sur
l'une de ses pièces
voilà et puis dans l'actualité qui mieux
que les habitants eux-mêmes pour
repenser leurs villages hameaux villes
près d'epinal les villageois ont été
mises à contribution pour tenter de
redynamiser le centre bourg un projet
participatif que nous détaille mari
daniel horowitz et anaïs galles devosge
télé à regarder
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
le charme champêtre de marieville 450
habitants ne saute pas aux yeux au vu de
sa rue principale mais cela va changer
avec un projet en cours à notre idée au
départ c'était déjà d'acquérir un toutes
ces anciennes bâtisses pour essayer de
faire quelque chose et plutôt qu'une
décider par nous même uniquement le
conseil on a dit on va demander la vie à
la population
tous ont été établies la mairie a donc
racheté 5000 mètres carrés sur cette
parcelle dans la grand'rue le projet
mûri ville rêve son centre c'est son nom
a pu prendre forme les habitants ont
donné leur avis au printemps dernier et
ils se sont retrouvés pour un premier
bilan faisant part de leurs idées voilà
qui est beaucoup de végétalisation ça
c'est important pour qu'on a un joli
coeur de village qui commercent parce
que ça montre aussi les habitants ont
rêvé leur village et la faisabilité du
projet a pris forme avec le cabinet
d'étude mandaté des locaux
professionnels pour des professions
libérales du logement du logement
seniors de l'activité avec une micro
brasserie et puis surtout un lieu de
rassemblement autour d'une petite
épicerie d'un café une petite
restauration
trois fermes seront conservés et dans
cette ancienne étable on imagine déjà la
microbrasserie tenu d'ailleurs par un
habitant de marieville le café
multiservices le verger et la place du
village cette dernière n'existait pas
son très attendu
maury ville fait partie de cinq villages
test et c'est également un des rares
effets positifs de la coved l'envi de
campagne a vu arriver et 60 habitants de
plus la dynamique devrait se poursuivre
d'ici 2023 une fois la transformation du
centre de la commune devenu réalité
voilà qui ne tardez pas trop vous n'avez
plus que quelques jours pour voir à
toulouse la plus célèbre des tapisseries
d'art médiéval je veux bien entendu
parler de la dame à la licorne est
exposée jusqu'au 16 janvier aux
abattoirs une oeuvre dont séverine le
pape la directrice nationale du
moyen-âge à cluny livre quelques secrets
au micro de nos confrères de la dépêche
agnès grimaldi
il s'agit d'une tenture de six pièces
qui relate par le biais de la dame d'une
dame de sa servante et 2 animaux la
licorne et le lion une allégorie des
cinq sens et d'un sixième sens devant
lequel je me tiens mon seul désir
sixième sens qui a été à l'époque
médiévale soit considéré comme un sens
plus spirituelle qui gouvernait les cinq
autres soit comme un sens de libre
arbitre ou la dame finalement décidé de
choisir ce qu'elle souhaite soit
davantage aller vers le charnel
puisqu'on peut interpréter son geste
comme le fait qu'elle puisse prendre un
très beau bijou % s'emparer soit au
contraire prononcé aux biens charnelle
ou bien
terrestres en se débarrassant d'un bijou
très très précieux et puis c'est noël
place maintenant à la magie et au cirque
anne judic de télénantes à rencontrer
pour nous deux très jeunes passionnés
qui ont fait leurs tout premiers pas sur
une piste aux étoiles regardez plutôt
[Musique]
elle fait le show sans la moindre
appréhension
âgé de 7 ans roux qui a fait évoluer ses
poneys devant le public depuis deux ans
déjà aux côtés de sa cousine nantaise
tara les fillettes sont la nouvelle
génération du cirque zavatta tâche fut
un spectacle
man j'aime bien faire du cirque c'est
simplement gens que j'aime dans la vie
c'est ce que je voulais je rêvais
toujours le faire quand j'étais petite à
l'esat
ici le cirque est une affaire de famille
alairac
pour qui en huit travers moi eh ben je
pensais qu'en vacher ordi ou conduire et
et pour qu'ils m'écoutent mieux et 20
aujourd'hui braver les gens de 9,1
l'engin s'est bien aller partie
moi j'aime bien qu'on les applaudissent
comme applaudissent à moi et j'aime bien
surtout l'écart assez pour les adultes
rien de plus normal que de plonger très
tôt les enfants dans le grand bain du
cirque ont en effet commencé très jeune
en piste qui samedi au public pour
qu'ils aillent pas honte d'être sur la
piste et puis puis comme ça ça nous
permet de voir bas vers quelle
orientation au niveau du spectacle on va
pouvoir voir les avec quoi une vie pas
comme les autres au rythme des
déplacements et des spectacles une vie
de nomade qui se perpétue depuis huit
générations
j'ai publics issus de 90 requis et noah
maintenant depuis depuis neuf ans qui
ont vu l'évolution de mes filles aînées
puis depuis les plus jeunes et puis je
suis donc c'est très sympa quoi sur
scène les générations se mêlent et les
spectateurs n'y sont pas indifférents
est ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit à travers le sycot le cirque cette
transmission qui se fait avec les jeunes
générations les attraits même yacout
émouvant derrière 1,6 million on dirait
que c'est trop mignon
mais les petites rêve déjà de plus grand
rokia se voit dompter des lions comme
son père tara elle voudrait faire de la
danse aérienne comme ses parents
[Musique]
ati
attention dans ce journal maintenant
vous allez en avoir plein les yeux en
effet jérôme et aubron de la chaîne nous
et au la chaîne de la voix du nord s'est
rendu à conti dans la somme et il n'a
pas eu de mal à trouver la maison de
josé vous allez le voir qui chaque année
par cette maison de mille feux pour le
plus grand plaisir des habitants
regardez ce reportage
dé village enneigé une armée de père
noël et même une tyrolienne bienvenue
dans le jardin enchanté de josé deneux
une bulle de rêve dont ils ouvrent
volontiers les portes aux curieux depuis
maintenant quatre ans
ça fait quand même à une respiration de
féerie de pas de joie pour moi c'est un
émerveillement
incroyable c'est joli c'est un moment
féerique et surtout que j'ai un nouveau
pv donc ça me faisait plaisir de
l'emmener et pour faire rêver petits et
grands josé a mis le paquet dans son
jardin de 800 m² ce passionné de noël et
quelques proches ont installé pas moins
de deux kilomètres de guirlandes
lumineuses et des écrans géants juste ce
qu'il faut pour raviver l'esprit de noël
je pense que c'était une tradition
qu'ils commençaient à ses pertes donc on
essaie de réveiller cette magie et même
chez les personnes âgées et des
personnes âgées qui viennent vous avez
vu
il on y retrouve une magie de noël
qu'ils ont perdu y retrouve une partie
de leur enfance après un mois de travail
les festivités commencent et les
visiteurs viennent parfois de loin pour
admirer le résultat on vient de la
région de chantilly lamorlaye je crois
qu'on voit même pas la quantité le temps
passe et plus les idées qu'il a parce
que c'est pas juste acheté est posée
c'est vraiment à ménager ses travailler
c'est s'est rassemblé ses maîtres des
univers
boulot de fou l'an dernier les
décorations de josé avait permis de
récolter 550 euros pour l'association
grandir sans cancer et l'action un creux
un pédiatrie un engagement solidaire que
le père noël lui-même vient saluer
chaque week end
[Musique]
voilà et puis pour finir ce journal de
bien belles images que l'on doit à la
chaîne 7 à limoges des images de
circonstance puisqu'il s'agit des
illuminations de noël dans cette ville
de limoges qui s'est parée de ses plus
beaux atours du jardin d'orsay jusqu'à
la place saint pierre je vous laisse en
profiter regardez
[Musique]
je
non
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
bonne fête de noël à tous on se retrouve
bien sûr pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]